this is the Vita 550 portable power
station from our partner growod which is
basically like a power bank you would
use to charge your iPhone but on a whole
new level it has 538 Watt hours of
battery packed into this portable
package which is over 43 times the
amount of battery that's packed into an
iPhone 14 pro but what makes this really
special is the huge number of ports and
outputs as well as the fact that it
supports three methods of charging
including solar charging which you can
bundle with the power station now I'll
explain how that works in just a minute
but first I've got to talk about the
crazy variety of outputs not only do you
get four USB ports including a USBC PD
Port up to 100 Watts Max for laptops
like the new 14 inch MacBook Pro but you
also get a wireless Qi charger on the
top with up to 15 watts of power for
convenient smartphone or accessory
recharging on the go just in case you
forget your charging cable but even
better it's got additional DC Outlets
including a Car Outlet which is super
useful for portable pumps like for
inflatable mattresses for camping or
floaties for swimming in the summer and
finally it's got three AC Outlets that
can surge up to 1200 watts of power
using the watt plus mode and I tested a
bunch of stuff with these ports I
plugged in my 140 watt power adapter for
my 16 inch MacBook Pro which is very
rare to see in a battery bank but then I
even added a bunch of other devices my
iPad Mini two sets of airpods pro and
iPhone on the wireless charger and of
course the MacBook Pro and all of them
were charging as you can see on the
displays and the airpods lights then I
decided to plug in both of my home pods
while charging the MacBook Pro works
just fine as you can see then I tested
out my beefy air filter her and turned
it up to the maximum fan speed which got
insanely loud and sucked up 111 watts of
power as you can see on the right side
of the built-in display which also shows
you the input wattage when charging the
voltage and the amount of battery
remaining if it continues to run at that
same wattage non-stop I even plugged in
three lithium battery chargers which are
for my power tools and all three were
charging just fine so you can see how
this power station can be really really
useful and then finally there is a light
on the front which gets crazy bright and
so useful for walking around at night
when you're camping or whatever else and
that right there is the main selling
point for the Vita 550 it's small and
portable so you can easily take it with
you on trips and it comes with this
really cool handle that pops out for
convenient carrying now growbot also has
a larger Infiniti 1500 power station
that they also sent to us for review
back in November which has been awesome
but the point of the Vita 550 is
portability while still being able to
run up to 90 of your essential outdoor
appliances and electronics and honestly
for 400 right now with the pre-sale
discount and the extra 30 off coupon
code it's actually a great deal if you
compare what you're getting to other
small power Banks and especially when
you consider the two-year warranty and
the fact that it comes with long lasting
lfp batteries that are rated for over 3
000 charging Cycles lasting around 8 to
10 years and that's even with the super
fast 500 watt charging which will charge
it up from zero to eighty percent in
just one hour or a full charge in 1.6
hours but one of my favorite features
about this power station is something
that other power Banks can't offer two
more unique ways to charge the first is
to plug it into a Car Outlet using the
include Cable in the box so you can
literally charge it while driving to
your camping trip or wherever else
you're going but the best method of all
is solar charging that can charge the
power station from zero to a hundred
percent and just 2.7 hours under direct
sunlight making it perfect for camping
trips without any nearby power they sent
us their 200 watt solar panel which is
so easy to set up just unfold the panels
stand it upright and use the included
cables to plug it directly into the
power station and as you can see it is
charging just imagine you're going on a
multi-day camping trip out in the wild
this portable station combined with the
solar panels can literally Supply you
with endless power for charging all of
your devices and everything else you
need to run while you're out there like
inflating mattresses powering a lantern
charging up your drone your iPad your
Apple watch whatever else and you can
ease easily bundle either a 100 watt
panel for an extra 199 dollars or a 200
watt panel for an extra
370 dollars with your Vita 550 which is
an absolute steal of a deal but keep in
mind that those prices include the
pre-order discount so if you want that
price use the link below to order now
and even if you're not much of a hiker
or camper the Vita 550 is great for
charging devices at home in your car at
your job site like for construction
workers that need to charge up their
power tool batteries and it can even be
a lifesaver in the case of a power
outage to run a 65 watt CPAP machine for
up to seven hours or even to keep your
fridge on so your food doesn't go bad or
of course things like your Wi-Fi router
if you need your electronics and then I
can't forget about the grow watt app
which you can use to add multiple grow
watt devices and it basically lets you
monitor the battery life the output
power the solar charging wattage and a
bunch of other things including actually
being able to turn the outputs on and
off straight from the app without having
to actually go and physically control it
so overall I'm really impressed by the
Vita 550 since it packs so many outputs
into a small and portable package that
doesn't take up much room in your car
and at just under 18 pounds of weight
you can easily take this carry around
with one hand so it's super convenient
and just the fact that you can keep this
thing charged up on the go with solar
panels makes it completely unique
solving so many issues for wild camping
so with that said if you're interested
in checking out the groa Vita 550 go
ahead and use the link below if you want
to lock in those great pre-order prices
basically up to 200 off including the
coupon code and if you prefer something
bigger or more powerful they also have
their Infinity 1500 power station on
sale right now for thirteen hundred
dollars and if you're curious to see how
much juice that model packs you can
check out our review of it right over
there so thanks grow out for sending us
the Vita 550 and hopefully you enjoyed
this video thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]